what an upsetting task you have had to
put this together i was listening to the
former health secretary jeremy hunt in
the house of commons a little earlier
who commissioned this report based
originally on 23 cases he said what has
been discovered during the course of
this has been beyond his darkest fears
talk to me about what you have uncovered
and the scale of it all
so as far as we're aware this is the
largest um
inquiry into a single service in the
history of the nhs
throughout the process i've been
supported by an amazing
multi-professional team of just over 90
midwives and doctors all with decades of
experience
we did start with a caseload of 23
families when we first reviewed those 23
cases we were of the unanimous view that
these were amongst the most serious
cases that we had seen in our careers
but of course once the news um got out
into the local system here in shropshire
that there was this uh independent
secretary of state uh review
the families just kept coming
we got to 60 we got 200 we got to 300
and then the numbers kept climbing so
what we've described today are the
reviews
1592 clinical incident reviews
undertaken by my expert independent team
it's hard for those numbers to sink in
as we said it started with 23 and so
many families draw into this
finding out about each other because i
would imagine when this happens to you
as a family you hope
that you
are the only ones but as you said as
this came out it was uncovered that this
went on over two decades at shrewsbury
and helford hospital trust
repeated failures what are the reasons
behind the repeated failures
so i think there are a range of reasons
first of all this was a trust that did
not investigate properly we know that
systems and structures of governance
clinical governance and investigation
has changed in our nhs over time and we
were careful to only ever judge the
trust against the accepted standards of
the time but each time we did that we
still found significant failings to
investigate uh failures to listen to
families and failure to learn
we came across action plans that even
when they were of a reasonable quality
and that wasn't often action plans that
were simply put on a shelf and
one of the things that my team
found most distressing
is that when they were reviewing cases
down the years down the line they kept
finding the same themes over and over
again
so my expert team of midwives and
doctors have said to me they've used
words like harrowing and distressing to
describe the work that they've needed to
do on behalf of the families in
shropshire
in this report you don't talk about
recommendations because whenever we hear
about a report that's been commissioned
into a scandal it talks about
recommendations you're very specific in
that you talk about essential and
immediate actions reading between the
lines you're basically saying this is so
bad this must not be the end of the
matter these changes have to be made
so there's no reading between the lines
at all we don't read between the lines
in our review team we say it how it is
these are you're absolutely right
immediate and essential actions or ieas
for short if you prefer the trust has
got more than 60 local actions for
learning and my team and i have an
absolute expectation that these are
delivered upon now that needs some
system changes the government has
announced a significant amount of
funding into maternity services um since
report one was published and further
funding again um in
before report two so that was that was
last week but we endorsed the findings
of the health select committee led by
jeremy hunt last year that said much
more funding needed to be required
needed to be provided and so we are
saying to the government that that
finding from the health select committee
must must must now happen
there's other immediate actions around
training around learning from situations
when mothers lose their lives trusts
have got to come together if they've all
delivered care
and you know there is just an awful lot
to do however we are confident that the
system the wider system from government
down to
um local regions down to trust boards
and wards
do understand the scale of the issue and
we will be watching carefully
to make sure that this does happen yeah
the trust have apologized today and they
have said that they have already started
work to make changes you mentioned those
60 specific actions for that particular
trust and 15
immediate and essential actions for all
maternity services in england
are we looking at a national crisis and
are you worried that services won't be
safe unless you get the level of funding
you've been talking about there which
the govern government haven't committed
to those levels of spending in this area
so i think the very positive thing that
has come out of what happened to so many
shropshire families
is that the level of scrutiny and
attention on maternity services is that
it is something that i've not seen in my
30-year career so it can feel difficult
when there's a harsh spotlight on a
particular service but i think much
positivity will come out of that i heard
the secretary of state stand up today to
say that he was accepting and endorsing
all of our immediate and essential
actions
that does mean
increased funding for workforce
that does mean
better standards seamless standards of
training across england
you know there is a lot to do but i am
confident that the attention on
maternity services is such that this
will now happen and happen at pace yeah
you have the health secretary support he
just needs the backing of the treasury
for funds talk to me about the families
involved i'm sure you'd like to pay
tribute to them today because we're
talking about mothers who have
campaigned
four years to get to this point and at
many points in the process i'm sure felt
like they were
a lone voice in the wind i think is how
i've heard um one family put it um can
you pay tribute to them today because
they're the ones that have got you to
this point and i'm sure they won't let
it up
absolutely what the first thing that i
did this morning as i launched um this
report was to pay tribute to the
families they were silenced for far too
long and many many families that the
quote about being a lone voice in the
wind came from the mummy of olivia
olivia died in 2002 and her mum appeared
on television in 2006 to try and get
someone to do something
it took the heroic efforts
of richard and rhiannon stanton davies
and kaylee and colin griffis after the
deaths of their babies kate in 2009 and
pippa in 2016 and to
get jeremy hunt who was then secretary
of state for health um to agree to this
uh review
there the cohort of families are known
as the secretary of state 23 the
original 23
um and they were made up of families who
had tried to get their voices heard for
so long
of course once the
news was out there that
this review had started the numbers
continued
to increase to where we got to today
and families have tried so hard they
described to me being exhausted by their
efforts to try to get their voices heard
but
they have done it we have done it and
now what we have thanks to those
families and my amazing review team is a
blueprint a safe road forward for
maternity services across england
yeah here's hoping that from this point
on family's voices are heard and it
leads to safer care nationwide and
senior midwife donna oxington thank you
so much for talking to us